victim's name is leo coppernick sir
seems he was killed in the costume store
[Music]
and then he was deposited here
staged so to speak
sorry
how much longer do you intend to hold it
all hostage
or is that the idea gather all the
suspects and interrogate each of us in
turn until the mysteries solve marvin
cochraners overrated playwright
celebrated hey right
oh i'm so sorry sir i can't read my own
handwriting
[Music]
there was
an incident
i'll kill you
it's as good as a confession it's not
just a conclusion it's comfortable
what do we have here
working late huh
he killed coppernick to hush up the
affair case closed i'm doing it again
aren't you sir
jump into conclusions yeah
a little bit
you've never heard of richard
a real life detective
i understand that you came to blows
tonight in question
it was me inspector i arrest you for the
murder of leo cotton
we have a serial killer on the loose
[Music]
please stand back he keeps the key under
the mat
we are no longer merely suspects
we are also
potential victims
so what did he do that made you
suspicious it wasn't so much what he did
it was more the way he did it how'd he
do it sort of
suspiciously right
you